because it's hard down 80 new shows from
2020. every time there's like a pop
culture boom a new app A New Concept a
new platform podcast YouTube social
media blogs back in the day websites
iPhone apps nft projects uh uh being a
rapper being an athlete these were not
things that people thought about as
major professions in the 1930s 40s 50s
and then everybody sees and then
everyone tries
having a successful podcast is hard
it doesn't mean I mean to me everybody
who watches this should try and do 10
episodes of a podcast because God forbid
AKA God willing you've got it like that
it's an amazingly fun career and
lucrative and you get to talk about what
you want but the reason things go down
after they get a little mature is
because it's hard people give up after
20 times posting on social on Tick Tock
or Instagram you're like oh I didn't go
viral shit's hard out here